أهلاً بكم مرة ثانية في سلسلة فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية، اسمي John watus وأنا المدير التقني للتعليم
في IBM Quantum. هذا هو الدرس التاسع في السلسلة وهو أول درس في الوحدة الثالثة اللي تتكلم عن الصياغة
العامة للمعلومات الكمية. لحد الآن كنا نستخدم الصياغة المبسطة
للمعلومات الكمية حيث الحالات الكمية تُمثَّل بمتجهات أعداد مركبة ذات معيار إقليدي يساوي
واحد. بالمقابل، في الصياغة العامة للمعلومات الكمية، الحالات الكمية تُمثَّل بواسطة
مصفوفات من نوع معين تُعرف بمصفوفات الكثافة. هذا الدرس الأول من الوحدة يركز على مصفوفات الكثافة تحديداً
وراح نوصل لماهيتها وطريقة عملها مع استمرار الدرس. مصفوفات الكثافة مفيدة جداً
وتقدم مزايا متعددة راح نناقشها. تسمح لنا بتمثيل فئة
أوسع من الحالات مقارنة بمتجهات الحالة الكمية، بما فيها حالات الأنظمة المتأثرة بالضوضاء مثلاً، وكذلك الاختيارات العشوائية
للحالات الكمية. راح نلقي نظرة أيضاً على كرة Bloch اللي تعطينا طريقة هندسية جميلة
وبسيطة للتفكير في حالات الـ qubit، وراح نشوف كيف ترتبط بمصفوفات الكثافة بطريقة
مذهلة فعلاً من خلال مصفوفات Pauli. أخيراً راح نناقش مصفوفات الكثافة في سياق الأنظمة
المتعددة، وبالأخص راح نشوف كيف تسمح لنا بوصف الحالات الكمية لأنظمة تُنظر إليها بشكل منعزل حتى عندما
تكون مترابطة مع أنظمة أخرى، وهذا يشمل احتمال أنها متشابكة مع أنظمة أخرى. هذا شيء مهم أن نكون قادرين
على فعله وما يسهل فعله ضمن الصياغة المبسطة للمعلومات الكمية. هذه نظرة عامة على
الدرس. راح نبدأ بأساسيات مصفوفات الكثافة بما فيها التعريفات المهمة وبعض الأمثلة، وراح
نناقش أيضاً كيف ترتبط بمتجهات الحالة الكمية. بعدها راح نتكلم عن التوافيق المحدبة لمصفوفات الكثافة أو بعبارة
أخرى ماذا يحصل لما ناخذ المتوسطات الموزونة لمصفوفات الكثافة. راح نبدأ بمثال محدد
وهو ما يُسمى بالحالة المختلطة بالكامل. راح نشوف كيف يمكن اعتبار الحالات الاحتمالية الكلاسيكية كحالات
خاصة من مصفوفات الكثافة، وراح نناقش كيف تدخل نظرية الطيف من الجبر الخطي في
هذا السياق. الجزء الثالث من الدرس عن كرة Bloch اللي توفر طريقة هندسية لرؤية حالات
الـ qubit المفردة كما ذكرت في بداية الدرس. وفي الجزء الرابع من الدرس راح نتكلم عن كيف تعمل مصفوفات الكثافة للأنظمة
المتعددة. راح نناقش حالات الجداء والحالات المترابطة بأنواعها المختلفة بما فيها الحالات المتشابكة وكذلك
مفهوم الحالة المختزلة وهي وصف بمصفوفة كثافة لحالة جزء معزول من نظام مركب
يمكن حسابها باستخدام عملية تُعرف بالأثر الجزئي. قبل ما ندخل في المحتوى التقني للدرس نفسه، من
المناسب أن نأخذ لحظات قليلة لتوضيح أهمية استخدام مصفوفات الكثافة. باستخدام الصياغة
المبسطة للمعلومات الكمية اللي ما تتضمن مصفوفات الكثافة، نقدر نوصف الخوارزميات الكمية مثل
خوارزمية Shor للتحليل إلى عوامل مثلاً بدون أي صعوبات. فليش نهتم بمصفوفات الكثافة
أو هذه الصياغة العامة للمعلومات الكمية أصلاً؟ في الحقيقة هناك أسباب متعددة. أولاً، مصفوفات الكثافة
تمثل فئة أوسع من الحالات الكمية مقارنة بمتجهات الحالة الكمية، بما فيها الحالات الكمية اللي فيها عدم يقين أو
عشوائية. هذا مهم لما نريد نمذجة تأثيرات الضوضاء على الحوسبة الكمية
مثلاً. ثانياً، باستخدام مصفوفات الكثافة نقدر نوصف الحالات الكمية لأجزاء معزولة من أنظمة مركبة مثل
حالات الأنظمة المتشابكة مع أنظمة أخرى واللي ربما مؤقتاً نختار تجاهلها. كما ذكرت في بداية
الدرس، هذا الشيء ما يسهل فعله بشكل طبيعي ضمن الصياغة المبسطة للمعلومات
الكمية. السبب الثالث هو أنه لما نستخدم مصفوفات الكثافة، المعلومات الكلاسيكية تظهر فعلياً كحالة
خاصة. فبدلاً من أن يكون عندنا ما هو أساساً تشابه بين الحالات الاحتمالية والعمليات عليها من
جهة، ومتجهات الحالة الكمية والعمليات الوحدوية من جهة أخرى، يصبح عندنا المعلومات الكمية والكلاسيكية
موصوفة معاً ضمن إطار رياضي واحد، وهذا ضروري جداً للدراسة الرياضية
للمعلومات الكمية. فإذا كنت جاد في فهم المعلومات الكمية على المستوى الرياضي، يُنصح بشدة
أن تتعلم عن مصفوفات الكثافة. نبدأ بتعريف مصفوفات
الكثافة. لغرض التعريف، نفترض أن X نظام و sigma مجموعة حالاته الكلاسيكية، وتذكر أنه
لما نستخدم هذا المصطلح، افتراضنا هو أن sigma منتهية وغير فارغة. وكالعادة يمكننا اختيار
أسماء مختلفة لو أردنا. مصفوفة الكثافة اللي توصف حالة النظام X هي مصفوفة ذات مدخلات
أعداد مركبة وصفوفها وأعمدتها موضوعة في تناظر مع مجموعة حالاته الكلاسيكية. وللتوضيح،
هو نفس التناظر للصفوف والأعمدة في نفس الوقت. هذا يعني أن مصفوفات
الكثافة دائماً مصفوفات مربعة. وبالإضافة إلى كونها مربعة، هناك شرطان يجب استيفاؤهما
وراح نوصل لهما قريباً. الناس عادة تستخدم حروف يونانية صغيرة معينة لتسمية مصفوفات
الكثافة. rho غالباً هو الخيار الأول، وخيارات شائعة أخرى تشمل sigma الصغيرة و tau كما هو موضح على
الشاشة. هذا مجرد اصطلاح لكن كالعادة هذه الاصطلاحات مفيدة لأنها تخلي الأشياء أسهل
في التعرف عليها. والآن نتكلم عن الشروط أو المتطلبات اللي لازم مصفوفات الكثافة تستوفيها لتكون
مصفوفات كثافة صالحة. هناك اثنان منها واللي راح أسويه هو أولاً أسردهما
وبعدين أناقش بتفصيل أكبر ماذا يعنيان. الشرط الأول هو أن مصفوفات
الكثافة لازم يكون أثرها واحد، أو بعبارة أخرى الأثر يساوي واحد. والشرط الثاني هو أن
مصفوفات الكثافة لازم تكون شبه موجبة التعريف. وفي كلتا الحالتين عندنا طرق رمزية مختصرة للتعبير عن
هذين الشرطين موضحة على الشاشة. الآن خلوني أناقش الشرطين بتفصيل أكبر.
الشرط الأول يشير إلى الأثر وهو دالة مهمة جداً معرّفة لجميع المصفوفات المربعة
وهو ببساطة مجموع المدخلات القطرية. وهنا معادلة تعبر عن ذلك
بشكل صريح. هناك الكثير مما يُقال عن الأثر ولماذا هو مهم، لكن الآن خلونا نلاحظ
خاصية أساسية جداً فيه وهي أنه دالة خطية. خصائص أخرى للأثر راح تظهر وراح نناقشها عندما
نحتاجها. لكن لنبقى مركزين على مصفوفات الكثافة، ننتقل للشرط الثاني وهذا الشرط هو أن
مصفوفات الكثافة شبه موجبة التعريف. هذا أيضاً مفهوم مهم يظهر في عدة مجالات في
الفيزياء والكيمياء والتحسين وتعلم الآلة ومواضيع أخرى، ويمكن التعبير عنه بعدة طرق مختلفة لكنها
متكافئة. طريقة واحدة للتعبير عنه هي أن نقول إن المصفوفة rho شبه موجبة التعريف إذا وُجدت مصفوفة M
بحيث rho تساوي M خنجرية ضرب M. واتضح أنه ما يفرق إذا طلبنا أن M نفسها تكون مصفوفة
مربعة أو إذا تخلينا عن هذا القيد. طريقة أخرى للتعبير عن معنى أن المصفوفة rho شبه موجبة
التعريف هي أن نقول إن rho هرميتية، يعني أنها تساوي مرافقها المنقول، وجميع
قيمها الذاتية أعداد حقيقية غير سالبة. بشكل عام المصفوفات الهرميتية ممكن
يكون عندها قيم ذاتية حقيقية فقط لكنها ممكن تكون سالبة. لكن إذا أضفنا القيد الإضافي أنه ما في
قيمة ذاتية سالبة نحصل على المصفوفات شبه الموجبة التعريف. وبالمناسبة إذا عندك
مصفوفة وتبي تعرف إذا كانت شبه موجبة التعريف، تقدر تحدد ذلك باستخدام هذا التوصيف. سهل جداً
تتحقق إذا كانت المصفوفة هرميتية أو لا، هذا شيء تقدر تشوفه بالعين. الأصعب هو حساب
القيم الذاتية لكن هذا شيء ما هو صعب كثير بالكمبيوتر لأنه توجد خوارزميات فعالة جداً للقيام
بذلك. والتوصيف الأخير اللي راح أذكره رغم وجود غيره هو أنه لكل متجه عمودي s عدد
مدخلاته يتوافق مع عدد صفوف وأعمدة rho، المتباينة الموضحة على
الشاشة صحيحة. بالكلام، bra s ضرب rho ضرب ket s لازم يكون عدد حقيقي غير
سالب. بالمناسبة ما هو واضح أن هذه التوصيفات كلها متكافئة لكنها كذلك. وخلوني أنوه بشكل صريح أن
الترميز اللي نستخدمه عادة للإشارة إلى أن المصفوفة rho شبه موجبة التعريف يبدو مثل rho أكبر من
أو تساوي صفر. لكن هذا مجرد ترميز مختصر وما يعني حرفياً أن rho أكبر من
أو تساوي صفر. rho مصفوفة فهذا ما يكون له معنى. وأيضاً ما يعني
أن كل مدخلات rho أكبر من أو تساوي صفر. بالتحديد توجد مصفوفات شبه موجبة
التعريف ومدخلاتها مو كلها غير سالبة، وتوجد مصفوفات مدخلاتها كلها غير
سالبة لكنها مو شبه موجبة التعريف. الفكرة وراء الترميز هي أن المصفوفات شبه الموجبة
التعريف هي مثل نظائر مصفوفية للأعداد الحقيقية غير السالبة. لكن هذا مجرد ترميز ومعناه هو
بالضبط ما ناقشناه سابقاً. الآن نلقي نظرة على بعض الأمثلة نبدأ بمثال على مصفوفة
شبه موجبة التعريف. في الحقيقة سهل جداً توليد مثال عشوائي لمصفوفة
شبه موجبة التعريف ببساطة باختيار مصفوفة M بشكل اعتباطي ثم حساب M خنجرية ضرب
M. مثلاً هنا مصفوفة M مو مميزة بشيء وفي الحقيقة
ولّدتها عشوائياً باختيار الأجزاء الحقيقية والتخيلية للمدخلات بشكل مستقل كأعداد صحيحة بين سالب 9 وموجب
9. فأي أنماط أو بنية هنا هي مجرد صدفة. بضرب
المرافق المنقول لـ M في M نحصل على هذه المصفوفة هنا وهي بالتالي شبه موجبة
التعريف. طبعاً هناك حد لمقدار الفهم اللي نقدر نكتسبه من مثال عشوائي لكنه يُظهر بعض
الخصائص المشتركة في المصفوفات شبه الموجبة التعريف بشكل أعم. بالتحديد راح تلاحظون
أن المدخلات القطرية يعني اللي على الخط من أعلى اليسار إلى أسفل اليمين كلها أعداد حقيقية غير
سالبة. وأيضاً المدخلات غير القطرية بشكل ما ليست كبيرة جداً مقارنة بالمدخلات القطرية المقابلة
يعني اللي في نفس الصف واللي في نفس العمود لأي مدخل غير قطري نتطلع
عليه. لكن هناك أكثر من هذا في القصة ومن المهم أن ندرك أن كون المصفوفة شبه موجبة التعريف هي
خاصية للمصفوفة ككل ومو بس شرط على المدخلات الفردية. هذا مثال على مصفوفة
شبه موجبة التعريف وتقدر بسهولة كبيرة تولّد أمثلة أخرى بنفس
الطريقة. الآن نلقي نظرة على بعض أمثلة مصفوفات الكثافة حيث بالإضافة إلى شرط شبه الموجبة التعريف عندنا أيضاً أن الأثر يساوي
واحد. هنا بعض أمثلة مصفوفات كثافة 2×2. الأثر يساوي
واحد في الحالات الأربع جميعها ونقدر نشوف أيضاً أن هذه مصفوفات هرميتية. فباستخدام التوصيف الثاني للمصفوفات
شبه الموجبة التعريف من قبل، كل ما يبقى هو التحقق أن القيم الذاتية كلها غير سالبة.
أترك ذلك لكم للتحقق إذا أردتم. لمصفوفات 2×2 ما هو صعب كثير حساب القيم الذاتية يدوياً
لكن تقدرون أيضاً تطلبون من الكمبيوتر يسويها. مثلاً تقدرون تستخدمون دالة eigenvalue في حزمة الجبر الخطي
في Python. نقدر أيضاً نحصل على مصفوفة كثافة ببساطة بأخذ أي مصفوفة
شبه موجبة التعريف غير صفرية وقسمتها على أثرها. مثلاً هنا مصفوفة الكثافة اللي نحصل عليها
بقسمة المثال اللي شفناه قبل شوي على أثره. القسمة على الأثر بهذا الشكل
راح تحافظ دائماً على خاصية شبه الموجبة التعريف وبالتأكيد راح نحصل على مصفوفة أثرها يساوي واحد بحكم أن
الأثر دالة خطية. هذه مجرد مجموعة صغيرة من الأمثلة وراح نشوف أكثر مع استمرار
الدرس. بعد كذا ناخذ لحظات قليلة لنناقش تفسير أو المعنى
الحدسي لمصفوفات الكثافة. أول شيء لازم نعترف فيه هو أنه ممكن يبدو غريب شوي
أننا نمثل حالة نظام بمصفوفة بدل متجه. بالمقابل في الصياغة
المبسطة للمعلومات الكمية نستخدم المتجهات لتمثيل الحالات بينما المصفوفات تحديداً المصفوفات الوحدوية
تمثل الإجراءات أو العمليات. هذه هي الطريقة اللي تشتغل فيها الرياضيات ورغم أنك
تقدر دائماً تفكر في المصفوفات على أنها تصف تطبيقات خطية، عادة ما نربط معنى حدسي مباشر
بالتطبيق الخطي المرتبط بمصفوفة كثافة معينة. مع ذلك، حقيقة أن
مصفوفات الكثافة هي فعلاً مصفوفات تطلع أنها جانب بالغ الأهمية فيها وراح نشوف
ذلك مع استمرارنا. لكن لنذكر مثال واحد بسرعة الآن، القيم الذاتية لمصفوفة كثافة معينة
تطلع أنها مهمة جداً لأنها توصف مقدار العشوائية أو عدم اليقين الكامن في الحالة
اللي توصفها مصفوفة الكثافة تلك. طريقة مختلفة للتفكير في مصفوفات الكثافة على المستوى الحدسي
تركز على مدخلات هذه المصفوفات. تذكر أن صفوف وأعمدة مصفوفات الكثافة موضوعة
في تناظر مع الحالات الكلاسيكية لأي نظام نتكلم عنه. فلكل مدخل عندنا
حالة كلاسيكية واحدة تقابل صف ذلك المدخل وحالة كلاسيكية واحدة تقابل عمود ذلك
المدخل. بالنسبة للمدخلات القطرية، هاتان الحالتان الكلاسيكيتان هما نفس الحالة وعشان كذا المدخلات القطرية
مميزة. وطريقة واحدة لتفسير المدخلات القطرية هي أنها احتمالات، وتحديداً هي
احتمالات أن تظهر الحالة الكلاسيكية المقابلة لو أجرينا قياس الأساس المعياري
على النظام اللي نوصف حالته الكمية. بالنسبة للمدخلات غير القطرية من جهة أخرى، عندنا حالة كلاسيكية واحدة تقابل الصف
لذلك المدخل وحالة كلاسيكية مختلفة تقابل العمود لذلك المدخل. وبشكل غير رسمي جداً
هذه المدخلات توصف درجة وجود هاتين الحالتين الكلاسيكيتين في تراكب كمي وكذلك
الطور النسبي بينهما. هذا ممكن يكون أوضح مع استمرار الدرس ولما ننظر بتمعن
أكثر في بعض الأمثلة المحددة. والتفاصيل ممكن ما تكون واضحة في هذه المرحلة لكن لا تخلوا هذا يزعجكم.
هذا غير رسمي جداً ومجرد فكرة حدسية تحتفظون فيها في خلفية
تفكيركم. بعد كذا نلقي نظرة على العلاقة بين مصفوفات الكثافة ومتجهات الحالة الكمية وهي متجهات
أعمدة ذات معيار إقليدي يساوي واحد. بس لنتذكر التعريف الرياضي، بفرض أن عندنا
متجه حالة كمية psi يمثل حالة نظام معين، مصفوفة الكثافة اللي تمثل نفس
الحالة الكمية تُعطى بواسطة ket psi ضرب bra psi كما هو موضح هنا على الشاشة. وللتوضيح، مؤشرات psi
تتوافق بطريقة ما مع الحالات الكلاسيكية لأي نظام نتكلم عنه وهذا راح يكون بالضبط نفس التوافق بين
صفوف وأعمدة مصفوفة الكثافة والحالات الكلاسيكية للنظام. إذا تخيلنا أن هناك n
حالة كلاسيكية للنظام وفكرنا في متجهات الأعمدة والصفوف كمصفوفات فإن ket هي مصفوفة n في 1
و bra هي مصفوفة 1 في n فلما نجري الضرب نحصل على مصفوفة n في
n. هذه راح تكون دائماً مصفوفة شبه موجبة التعريف بحكم شكلها فعلياً وأيضاً أثرها يساوي
واحد بحكم أن psi متجه وحدوي وراح نشوف ذلك بتفصيل أكبر
قريباً. الحالات الكمية اللي تُمثَّل بمصفوفات كثافة من هذا الشكل تُسمى حالات
نقية. هنا بعض الأمثلة. أولاً نأخذ هذه الحالة
هنا وهي شبيهة بحالة الموجب إلا أن المدخل المقابل للحالة الكلاسيكية واحد هو
تخيلي. إذا حسبنا المرافق المنقول راح نحصل على إشارة سالبة لأن المرافق المركب لـ i هو
سالب i وإذا أجرينا الضرب راح نحصل على المصفوفة الموضحة هنا على الشاشة. هي هرميتية كما نقدر
نشوف مباشرة بالنظر إليها وتصادف أن عندها قيمة ذاتية واحدة تساوي واحد وقيمة ذاتية واحدة تساوي
صفر. فهي شبه موجبة التعريف وأثرها يساوي واحد فهي مصفوفة كثافة كما هو
متوقع. نقدر نحسب مصفوفات الكثافة المقابلة للأساس المعياري وأساس الموجب-السالب بطريقة مشابهة وتلك مصفوفات الكثافة
موضحة هنا. وهنا مثال آخر لمتجه حالة كمية صادف أنه
ظهر في الدرس الأول من السلسلة. وإذا حسبنا المرافق المنقول ثم ضربنا
نحصل على مصفوفة الكثافة الموضحة هنا. مرة أخرى هي هرميتية و
أثرها يساوي واحد وإذا حسبتم القيم الذاتية راح تلقون أن مرة أخرى عندها قيمة ذاتية واحدة تساوي واحد وقيمة ذاتية
واحدة تساوي صفر. وبالمناسبة هذه خاصية مشتركة لجميع الحالات النقية. دائماً عندها قيمة ذاتية واحدة
تساوي واحد وباقي القيم الذاتية كلها صفر. بشكل عام لمتجه حالة كمية عشوائي تماماً
psi بأي عدد من المدخلات، إذا ضربنا ket في bra psi نحصل على
مصفوفة كثافة تبدو هكذا. لاحظوا بالتحديد أن المدخلات القطرية دائماً أحد
مدخلات psi مضروباً في مرافقه المركب واللي نقدر نعبر عنه بديلاً بمربع القيمة المطلقة لذلك المدخل. وهذه
طريقة لنرى أن الأثر راح يكون دائماً يساوي واحد. وهي أيضاً متسقة مع الملاحظة اللي ذكرتها سابقاً في الدرس عن أن
المدخلات القطرية لمصفوفة الكثافة تخبرنا ماهي الاحتمالات لرؤية كل حالة كلاسيكية ممكنة
لو أجرينا قياس الأساس المعياري. وملاحظة أخيرة هنا
ما في مشكلة تتعلق بالأطوار الشاملة لمصفوفات الكثافة. حالتان كميتان متطابقتان إذا وفقط إذا كانت مصفوفتا
الكثافة متساويتين. بالتحديد افترض أن عندنا متجهي حالة كمية psi و phi
متكافئين حتى طور شامل، يعني نقدر نعبر عن أحدهما phi مثلاً بالآخر ضرب
عدد مركب على دائرة الوحدة. إذا حسبنا تمثيل مصفوفة الكثافة لـ phi فاللي راح
نلقاه هو أن عامل الطور الشامل يُضرب في مرافقه المركب وهذا يعطينا واحد ف
يختفي فعلياً ونبقى بالضبط بنفس مصفوفة الكثافة اللي نحصل عليها من psi. فهذا نوعاً ما
ميزة إضافية لطيفة. وبشكل أعم ما في أي مشكلة تتعلق بالتكافؤ حتى الأطوار الشاملة أبداً لما نشتغل
بمصفوفات الكثافة. هذا أساساً انحلال موجود لما نستخدم متجهات الحالة الكمية بدلاً
من مصفوفات الكثافة لتمثيل الحالات الكمية. مصفوفات الكثافة تملك خاصية أساسية وهي أن التوافيق
المحدبة لمصفوفات الكثافة تمثل اختيارات احتمالية أو عشوائية للحالات
الكمية. طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك هي أن مصفوفات الكثافة يمكن حساب متوسطها معاً بطريقة ذات معنى وهذا
شيء ما نقدر نسويه مع متجهات الحالة الكمية. لشرح هذا بتفصيل أكبر نبدأ بالحالة اللي عندنا فيها
مصفوفتا كثافة rho و sigma تمثلان حالات كمية لنظام ما. تخيلوا أن
النظام يُحضَّر في الحالة rho باحتمال p لاختيار ما لـ p بين صفر وواحد وغير ذلك
النظام يُحضَّر في الحالة sigma. مثلاً ربما p يساوي 1/2 ف
ممكن نتخيل أن شخص يرمي عملة عادلة وإذا طلعت وجه يقوم بعملية تترك النظام في
الحالة rho وغير كذا إذا طلعت العملة كتابة يقوم بعملية مختلفة تترك النظام في
الحالة sigma. السؤال الآن هو ما هي حالة النظام؟ وللتوضيح
نحن مهتمون بحالة النظام بمعزل عن أي معلومات أخرى ممكن تكون موجودة عن
أي تحضير تم إجراؤه. مثلاً تخيلوا أننا ما عندنا وصول للعملة أو
ذاكرة الشخص اللي أجرى تحضير الحالة. والجواب على هذا السؤال هو أنه ببساطة المتوسط الموزون لمصفوفتي الكثافة
p ضرب rho زائد 1 ناقص p ضرب sigma. هذا بالمناسبة مماثل تماماً
لما كان راح يصير لو أن rho و sigma مو مصفوفات كثافة بل كانت متجهات احتمالية
تمثل حالات احتمالية. فهذا مو شيء صادم أو غامض بل هو شيء
ربما مألوف من نظرية الاحتمالات. نسوي هذا النوع من المتوسطات طول الوقت لما نحسب الاحتمالات ونفكر
في الاختيارات العشوائية الكلاسيكية. والنقطة هي أن هذا يشتغل أيضاً لمصفوفات الكثافة. لكن لاحظوا أنه ما
يشتغل لمتجهات الحالة الكمية. يعني ما تقدر بشكل عام تحسب متوسط متجهي حالة
كمية بهذا الشكل وتأمل تحصل على متجه حالة كمية صالح. وإذا حاولت عادة راح تحصل على متجه
معياره الإقليدي ما يساوي واحد. لكن مع مصفوفات الكثافة المتوسطات الموزونة بهذا الشكل راح تكون دائماً
مصفوفات كثافة صالحة. والأهم أن مصفوفة الكثافة اللي تحصل عليها راح تمثل ذلك الاختيار العشوائي بطريقة
ذات معنى. هذا يتعمم للاختيارات العشوائية اللي فيها أكثر من بديلين.
بالتحديد إذا عندنا m مصفوفة كثافة ممكنة ومتجه احتمالي بـ m مدخل واحد
لكل مصفوفة كثافة والنظام يُحضَّر في كل حالة ممكنة بالاحتمال المقابل
فإن المتوسط الموزون لمصفوفات الكثافة تلك يصف الحالة الناتجة للنظام. وبالمناسبة لما
نشير إلى توفيقة محدبة من مصفوفات الكثافة هذا هو قصدنا. التوفيقة المحدبة هي ببساطة توفيقة خطية
حيث المعاملات تشكل متجه احتمالي. هذه راح تكون دائماً مصفوفة
كثافة. وطريقة بسيطة ومختصرة لقول ذلك بمصطلحات رياضية هي أن مجموعة كل مصفوفات الكثافة
المقابلة لنظام معين هي مجموعة محدبة. فإذا كان عندنا مثلاً m متجه حالة
كمية psi 0 إلى psi m ناقص واحد مع احتمالات p0 إلى pm ناقص واحد تشكل مجتمعة
متجه احتمالي والنظام يُحضَّر في الحالة psi k باحتمال pk لكل k فإن
الحالة الناتجة للنظام توصفها مصفوفة الكثافة الموضحة هنا على الشاشة. بالتحديد نحن ما نحسب متوسط
متجهات الحالة الكمية نفسها بل نحسب متوسط مصفوفات الكثافة المقابلة
لها. بشكل عام حالة مثل هذه ما راح يكون لها تمثيل كمتجه حالة كمية
واحد إلا إذا كان يصير شيء بديهي مثل أن جميع متجهات الحالة الكمية متكافئة حتى طور شامل أو أن كل الاحتمالات
ما عدا واحد تساوي صفر. ما راح نحصل على حالة كمية نقية من عملية كهذه بل راح نحصل على ما
يُسمى حالة كمية مختلطة حيث يوجد عدم يقين متأصل. نلقي نظرة على مثال
بسيط. افترض أن عندنا qubit وباحتمال 1/2 يُحضَّر الـ qubit في حالة الصفر وغير كذا
يُحضَّر في حالة الموجب. هنا مصفوفة الكثافة اللي نحصل عليها بحساب المتوسط كما
وصفت. نحسب مصفوفات الكثافة المقابلة للحالتين الممكنتين ونضربها بالاحتمالات المقابلة ونجمع
النتائج. اللي نحصل عليه هو فعلاً مصفوفة كثافة. هي هرميتية وأثرها يساوي واحد
وإذا حسبتم القيم الذاتية لهذه المصفوفة راح تحصلون على عددين حقيقيين موجبين وهما يصادف أنهما عددان لازم يكونان مألوفين
لكم الآن: مربع جيب التمام لـ pi على 8 ومربع الجيب لـ pi على 8 أو حوالي 0.85 و
0.15. ما في متجه حالة كمية واحد يمثل الحالة. مو حالة نقية. بعد كذا نلقي نظرة على
مصفوفة كثافة معينة تمثل حالة كمية لـ qubit مفرد تُعرف بالحالة المختلطة
بالكامل. هذه الحالة تظهر بشكل متكرر فمن الجيد أن يكون لها اسم وهي أيضاً مثال جيد لأنها
توضح خاصية مهمة لمصفوفات الكثافة. يوجد في الحقيقة حالة مختلطة بالكامل معرّفة بشكل مماثل لأي
نظام لكن الآن راح نركز على هذه الحالة لـ qubit مفرد لنبقي الأمور
بسيطة. افترض أننا نحدد حالة qubit عشوائياً لتكون إما حالة الصفر أو حالة الواحد كل منها باحتمال
يساوي 1/2 تماماً مثل بت عشوائي منتظم. نقدر نحسب تمثيل مصفوفة الكثافة لهذه
الحالة بالطريقة المعتادة. ناخذ المتوسط لتمثيلي مصفوفة الكثافة للحالتين. هكذا
يبدو بشكل مصفوفات واللي نحصل عليه هو مصفوفة الوحدة مقسومة على
اثنين. هذه الحالة تُعرف بالحالة المختلطة بالكامل وهي أساساً تمثل عدم يقين كامل أو أقصى
عن الـ qubit تماماً مثل ما يمثل متجه احتمالي منتظم أقصى عدم يقين في
السياق الاحتمالي الكلاسيكي. بشكل عام لأي نظام اعتباطي الحالة المختلطة بالكامل هي
الحالة اللي نحصل عليها باختيار حالة أساس معياري بشكل منتظم وتمثيل مصفوفة الكثافة راح يكون
مصفوفة الوحدة مقسومة على البعد أو ما يعادله عدد الحالات الكلاسيكية لذلك
النظام. في هذه المرحلة هذا مجرد مصطلحات لكن إذا غيرنا الإعداد شوي راح نشوف خاصية مهمة
لمصفوفات الكثافة. بالتحديد نفترض أننا نغير الإجراء و
بدل حالتي الأساس المعياري صفر وواحد نستبدلهما بحالتي الموجب والسالب. هذه المرة نبدأ
بالتعبير الموضح على الشاشة لكن إذا أجرينا الحسابات نحصل على بالضبط نفس
مصفوفة الكثافة. هي مصفوفة الوحدة مقسومة على اثنين. فهي نفس الحالة كما قبل،
الحالة المختلطة بالكامل. هذا كما يقولون ميزة ومو خلل. الإجراءان في الحقيقة
مختلفان لكن إذا كل اللي عندك هو الـ qubit الناتج ما في طريقة فيزيائية تقدر تميز بينهما
حتى بالمعنى الإحصائي. مثلاً لو أجريت قياس الأساس المعياري على هذا الـ qubit
بعد تنفيذ الإجراء الأول من الواضح راح تحصل على النتيجة صفر باحتمال 1/2 والنتيجة واحد باحتمال 1/2. لكن أيضاً راح تحصل على
بالضبط نفس احتمالات النتائج للإجراء الثاني. ونفس الشيء صحيح لأي اختبار آخر ممكن
تبتكره بافتراض أنك تختبر الـ qubit نفسه فقط. بشكل عام مصفوفات الكثافة ما توصف كيف تم تحضير النظام.
هي بس تخبرك ماذا سيحصل لو سويت أشياء بذلك النظام في المستقبل سواء كان ذلك إجراء
عمليات أو قياسات. وفي الحقيقة مصفوفات الكثافة مثالية في هذا
الصدد. إذا بديلان مختلفان أسفرا عن نفس مصفوفة الكثافة فما يمكن التمييز بينهما حتى
إحصائياً. لكن إذا مصفوفتا الكثافة مختلفتان فراح يكون هناك طريقة ما للتمييز بينهما مو
بالضرورة بشكل قاطع لكن بالمعنى الإحصائي. لما نستخدم الصياغة العامة للمعلومات
الكمية، المعلومات الكلاسيكية تظهر أساساً كحالة خاصة. وراح أشرح الآن كيف يشتغل
هذا الشيء. تحديداً راح نشوف كيف يمكن تمثيل الحالات الاحتمالية بمصفوفات
الكثافة. نبدأ بالحالات الكلاسيكية بمثال
بسيط. هنا تمثيلات مصفوفة الكثافة لحالتي الأساس المعياري صفر وواحد لـ
qubit. نربط هذه الحالات بالحالتين الكلاسيكيتين 0 و1 وبالتالي نقدر نفكر في مصفوفات الكثافة هذه على أنها
تمثل تلك الحالات. هذا بسيط جداً ونقدر بسهولة نعمم
المثال. إذا كان عندنا نظام مجموعة حالاته الكلاسيكية هي sigma فإن الحالة الكلاسيكية a تُمثَّل بـ أو
تُربط بمصفوفة الكثافة ket a bra a. تلك المصفوفة عندها واحد وحيد في
المدخل القطري اللي صفه وعموده يقابلان الحالة الكلاسيكية a وكل مدخل آخر
صفر. الحالات الاحتمالية تُمثَّل بتوافيق محدبة من مصفوفات بهذا الشكل وهذا طبيعي
بالنظر لما نعرفه عن مصفوفات الكثافة وكيف تعمل، تحديداً أن التوافيق المحدبة لمصفوفات الكثافة تمثل اختيارات عشوائية أو
احتمالية للحالات الكمية. مثلاً نفترض أن
عندنا نظام X مجموعة حالاته الكلاسيكية تشمل الأعداد الصحيحة من 0 إلى n ناقص واحد لعدد صحيح موجب n.
طبعاً ما في خسارة كبيرة في العمومية بافتراض أن مجموعة حالاتنا الكلاسيكية بهذا الشكل. لو كان عندنا
مجموعة حالات كلاسيكية مختلفة نقدر ببساطة نعيد تسمية الحالات الكلاسيكية بهذا الشكل. وعادة مريح جداً أن نفترض أن
مجموعات حالاتنا الكلاسيكية تبدو هكذا بشكل كبير لأن هذا يسهّل كتابة الأشياء بشكل صريح بدلالة
المتجهات والمصفوفات. بفرض أن عندنا حالة احتمالية للنظام X
ممثلة بمتجه احتمالي بالطريقة المعتادة، نقدر نربط هذه الحالة الاحتمالية بمصفوفة
كثافة كما هو موضح على الشاشة. ناخذ المتوسط الموزون لمصفوفات الكثافة المقابلة
للحالات الكلاسيكية المختلفة واللي نحصل عليه هو مصفوفة كثافة قطرية. بالتحديد نشوف الاحتمالات
على قطر هذه المصفوفة وكل مدخل آخر يساوي صفر. طبعاً هذه مصفوفة كثافة
نتوقع أن يكون هذا صحيح لكن نقدر أيضاً نستنتجه مباشرة. هي مصفوفة هرميتية وأثرها
يساوي واحد لأن الاحتمالات مجموعها واحد. وفي حالة المصفوفة القطرية القيم الذاتية هي المدخلات القطرية
وكلها غير سالبة لأنها احتمالات. لاحظوا أيضاً أن كل
مصفوفة كثافة قطرية يعني اللي مدخلاتها غير القطرية كلها صفر لازم تبدو هكذا. فباختصار
الحالات الاحتمالية يمكن ربطها بمصفوفات كثافة قطرية. لاحظوا بالمناسبة أن هذا متسق مع
التفسير غير الرسمي لمدخلات مصفوفات الكثافة اللي ذكرته في بداية الدرس. بالتحديد ما في شيء في
تراكب كمي هنا. هو أساساً مجرد عشوائية كلاسيكية وبالتالي كل المدخلات غير القطرية
تساوي صفر. في وقت سابق من هذه السلسلة ناقشنا نظرية الطيف وسويناها
تحديداً للمصفوفات الوحدوية في سياق تقدير الطور. نظرية الطيف أعم
من كذا، يعني أنها تخبرنا شيء عن فئة أوسع من المصفوفات وليس فقط المصفوفات الوحدوية.
وبالتحديد تنطبق على فئة من المصفوفات تُسمى المصفوفات الطبيعية واللي تشمل جميع المصفوفات وكذلك
المصفوفات الوحدوية. اللي راح نسويه الآن هو نلقي نظرة على صيغة مختلفة لهذه النظرية هذه المرة نركز فقط على
المصفوفات شبه الموجبة التعريف وبعدها راح نشوف أنها تخبرنا شيء مثير جداً وبالغ الأهمية عن مصفوفات
الكثافة. افترض أن P أي مصفوفة شبه موجبة التعريف وهذا يشمل أي مصفوفة كثافة وكذلك أي
مصفوفة شبه موجبة التعريف اللي ما يصادف أن أثرها يساوي واحد. P شبه موجبة التعريف فلازم
تكون مربعة أو بعبارة أخرى n في n لاختيار ما لـ n وراح نحتاج نشير لهذا العدد n فخلوا n يُختار
بشكل مناسب. أو طريقة أخرى لقول كل هذا هي نفترض أن P هي n في n. اللي تخبرنا النظرية في هذه الحالة هو أنه
لازم يوجد أساس متعامد معياري من المتجهات نسميه psi 0 إلى psi n ناقص واحد مع أعداد حقيقية غير سالبة
lambda 0 إلى lambda n ناقص واحد بحيث P يمكن التعبير عنها كما هو موضح
هنا على الشاشة. بالكلام إذا ضربنا كل lambda k في ket psi k ضرب bra psi k ثم
جمعنا على جميع k من 0 إلى n ناقص واحد فنحصل على P. هذا يُسمى تحليل
طيفي لـ P. كل lambda k هي بالضرورة قيمة ذاتية لـ P وكل psi هو متجه ذاتي وحدوي لـ P
يقابل تلك القيمة الذاتية. إذا رجعتم للدرس السابع عن تقدير الطور راح تلقون نظرية مشابهة
للمصفوفات الوحدوية. هناك القيم الذاتية هي أعداد مركبة على دائرة الوحدة بدل أعداد حقيقية غير سالبة
لكن ما عدا ذلك نفس الفكرة. وهذه فعلاً مجرد حالتان خاصتان من نظرية أعم تُعرف بـ
نظرية الطيف. ما تشتغل لكل مصفوفة، تحتاج المصفوفة تبادل مع
مرافقها المنقول وهذا معنى أن المصفوفة طبيعية. لكن فعلاً دائماً عندنا
هذا لكل من المصفوفات الوحدوية والمصفوفات شبه الموجبة التعريف وللمصفوفات الهرميتية بشكل أعم حيث
دائماً راح يكون عندنا قيم ذاتية حقيقية لكن مو بالضرورة غير سالبة. هذه صيغة
نظرية الطيف فقط للمصفوفات شبه الموجبة التعريف والآن نشوف ماذا تخبرنا عن مصفوفات
الكثافة. اللي تخبرنا هو أنه لأي مصفوفة كثافة n في n اعتباطية نقدر دائماً نعبر عنها كتوفيقة محدبة
من n حالة نقية. وأيضاً نقدر ناخذ تلك الحالات النقية الـ n لتكون
متعامدة. هذا ينتج مباشرة من النظرية مع حقيقة أساسية من الجبر الخطي وهي أن
مجموع القيم الذاتية لأي مصفوفة يساوي دائماً أثر تلك المصفوفة. بعبارة أخرى كل اللي نسويه
هنا هو إعادة تسمية القيم الذاتية p0 إلى pn ناقص واحد ثم ملاحظة أنه لما نسوي كذا و
نجمعها في متجه بُعده n نحصل بالضرورة على متجه احتمالي لأنها كلها لازم تكون غير سالبة ومجموعها يساوي
أثر rho وهو واحد لأن rho مصفوفة كثافة. هذا بسيط جداً لكنه
فعلاً أساسي جداً من الناحية المفاهيمية. اللي يخبرنا هو أن كل مصفوفة كثافة بغض
النظر عن مدى تعقيدها ممكن تنشأ من اختيار أساس متعامد معياري لأي نظام
نتكلم عنه ثم اختيار حالة كمية عشوائياً من ذلك الأساس وفقاً لاختيار ما للاحتمالات
إذا ما كان واضح فوراً ليش هذا مثير أو مهم فلا بأس. لكن فعلاً نستخدم هذه
الحقيقة بشكل متكرر جداً لما نستدل عن مصفوفات الكثافة. وفي الحقيقة التعبير عن مصفوفة كثافة معينة
بهذا الشكل غالباً هو أول شيء نسويه لما نبي نفهمها
بشكل أفضل. هنا مثال. تذكروا مصفوفة الكثافة اللي توصلنا لها سابقاً لما اخترنا عشوائياً بين
حالة الصفر وحالة الموجب كل منها باحتمال 1/2 واللي كما حسبنا مصفوفة كثافتها
تبدو هكذا. حالة الصفر وحالة الموجب ليستا متعامدتين فهذا ليس تحليل
طيفي. لكن إذا حسبنا واحد واللي نقدر نسويه بالكمبيوتر أو يدوياً في حالة مثل هذه فاللي
نحصل عليه هو هذا التعبير لمصفوفة الكثافة حيث القيم الذاتية هي هذه الأعداد اللي تظهر باستمرار و
حيث المتجهات الذاتية المقابلة يمكن اختيارها كما هو موضح هنا في الأسفل على الشاشة. ومرة أخرى شفنا هذه المتجهات من قبل مثلاً في
سياق لعبة CHSH في الدرس الرابع. فهذا مثير للاهتمام. وفقاً
للتعبير الأصلي هذه الحالة هي اللي نحصل عليها بالاختيار المنتظم بين حالتين هما حالة الصفر و
حالة الموجب. لكن في الحقيقة نحصل على نفس مصفوفة الكثافة بالضبط بالاختيار العشوائي بين حالتين نقيتين
لكننا ننحاز بشدة جداً نحو واحدة منهما حوالي 85% للأولى وحوالي 15% فقط
للثانية. فبمعنى ما هناك فعلاً عشوائية أقل متأصلة في الحالة مما بدا في البداية.
هناك طريقة هندسية جميلة جداً للتفكير في الحالات الكمية لـ qubit مفرد وتصورها تُعرف
بكرة Bloch. هي تشتغل بس لـ qubit مفرد. للأنظمة اللي عندها ثلاث
حالات كلاسيكية أو أكثر بما فيها اثنين أو أكثر من الـ qubit معاً ما تشتغل. فهي محدودة جداً لكن
مع ذلك هي طريقة ممتازة للتفكير في حالات qubit مفرد. كان ممكن نقدمها
من الدرس الأول في السلسلة عن الأنظمة المفردة لكنها مو ضرورية فعلاً لفهم كيف تشتغل المعلومات الكمية وأيضاً عندها
ارتباط جميل جداً بمصفوفات الكثافة فتتناسب طبيعياً مع هذا الدرس. وفي الحقيقة راح أشرحها
بطريقة مختلفة شوي عن الطريقة اللي تُشرح فيها عادة باستخدام مصفوفات الكثافة لاشتقاقها
فعلياً. فإذا كنت تعرف كرة Bloch من قبل هذا الشرح ممكن يكون مختلف شوي عن
الطريقة اللي تعلمتها فيها أول مرة لكن في النهاية لازم يكون متكافئ. راح نبدأ بالتفكير في
الحالات النقية الممكنة لـ qubit أولاً ممثلة بمتجهات الحالة
الكمية. حتى طور شامل كل متجه حالة كمية لـ qubit يمكن التعبير عنه كما
هو موضح هنا على الشاشة. لنكون دقيقين عندنا عددان حقيقيان theta و phi وراح نفكر
في هذين العددين على أنهما زوايا مُعبَّر عنها بالراديان. العدد الأول theta بين 0 و pi أو ما يعادل زاوية
بين 0 و180 درجة. والعدد الثاني phi بين 0 و 2 pi شاملاً 0 لكن ليس 2
pi. يعني أي زاوية بين 0 و360 درجة. مدخل الصفر لمتجهنا هو
جيب تمام theta على 2 وهذا عدد حقيقي بين 0 و1 وبالتحديد هو بالضرورة غير سالب.
ومدخل الواحد لمتجهنا هو e أس i ضرب phi ضرب جيب theta على 2 وهذا ممكن
يكون أي عدد مركب على أو داخل دائرة الوحدة المركبة. هذا دائماً متجه وحدوي أو
بعبارة أخرى هو متجه حالة كمية صالح. ولأي متجه حالة كمية لـ qubit معطى نقدر دائماً نلقى
متجه بهذا الشكل متكافئ معه حتى طور شامل. بالتحديد نقدر دائماً
نضرب المتجه المعطى بطور شامل ليصبح مدخل الصفر عدد حقيقي غير سالب ونختار أي
theta يعطينا ذلك المدخل ثم نختار phi لتطابق مدخل الواحد. مقدار مدخل الواحد راح
يتوافق دائماً بالضرورة مع جيب theta على اثنين بافتراض أننا بدأنا بمتجه
وحدوي. الآن ما هو بالضبط صحيح أن theta و phi يتحددان بشكل وحيد من أي متجه حالة كمية بدأنا
به لكنه تقريباً كذلك. دائماً راح يكون هناك قيمة وحيدة لـ theta بين صفر و pi تشتغل
وعادة هناك قيمة وحيدة لـ phi تشتغل. لكن في حالتين خاصتين هذا مو صحيح. بالتحديد إذا بدأنا بـ
حالة أساس معياري فإن theta راح يكون إما صفر أو pi وفي كلتا الحالتين ما يفرق فعلاً ماهي phi. هي
غير ذات صلة بالكامل. لما theta يساوي صفر جيب تمام theta على 2 يساوي 1 وجيب theta على 2
يساوي صفر فنحن نضرب e أس i ضرب phi في صفر فما يفرق ماهي phi.
وإذا theta يساوي pi فهذه المرة جيب التمام يساوي صفر والجيب يساوي واحد فعندنا e أس i ضرب phi ضرب ket 1 لكن تلك
المتجهات كلها متكافئة حتى طور شامل فمرة أخرى ما يفرق ماهي phi. لكن إذا theta كانت بالضبط
بين صفر و pi فدائماً راح يكون هناك قيمة وحيدة لـ phi تشتغل. وبالمناسبة هذا الانحلال
المحتمل في قيمة phi للحالتين الخاصتين راح يكون منطقي تماماً لما نشوف الصورة الهندسية
بعد شوي. الآن نحسب مصفوفة الكثافة المرتبطة بمتجه حالة بالشكل اللي حددناه
قبل شوي. فهذه راح تكون حالة نقية لـ qubit. لنسوي هذا نضرب المتجه
في مرافقه المنقول كالعادة وعلى الشاشة تعبير عن المصفوفة اللي نحصل عليها بحساب
المرافق المنقول وإجراء الضرب. الآن تماماً مثل كل مصفوفة 2×2
هناك طريقة وحيدة للحصول على هذه المصفوفة بأخذ توفيقة خطية من مصفوفات Pauli
بما فيها مصفوفة الوحدة. بالتحديد نقدر نحصل على هذه المصفوفة باختيار معاملات
مصفوفات Pauli كما هو موضح هنا على الشاشة. نضع اثنين في المقام لأن هذا راح يخلي
كل شيء يطلع بشكل جميل. ما في شيء يجبرنا على هذا لكن نقدر ومن المفيد نسوي كذا. لكن بعيداً
عن هذا الاختيار الشكلي ما في حرية هنا. هذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة للحصول على هذه المصفوفة بأخذ توفيقة خطية من مصفوفات Pauli وذلك
لأن مصفوفات Pauli بما فيها مصفوفة الوحدة هي أساس لفضاء المتجهات لجميع المصفوفات 2×2. طريقة واحدة
للتحقق من صحة هذا التعبير هي استخدام بعض المتطابقات المثلثية الأساسية. وبالتحديد إذا ابتعدت من الطريق
للحظة هنا عندنا بعض المتطابقات اللي راح تفي بالغرض. فإذا أردت أوقف الفيديو أو
خذ لقطة شاشة وشوف إذا تقدر تحصل على التعبير الثاني لمصفوفة الكثافة في الأسفل من الأول. فباختصار أي حالة نقية لـ
qubit معبَّر عنها كمصفوفة كثافة يمكن كتابتها كتوفيقة خطية من مصفوفات Pauli كما هو موضح على
الشاشة لـ theta بين 0 و pi و phi بين 0 و 2 pi. لاحظوا أن عندنا بالضبط
نفس الانحلال كما قبل وهو أن phi غير ذات صلة لما theta تكون إما صفر أو pi. وهذه المرة نقدر فعلاً
نشوف ذلك بوضوح أكبر لأن جيب theta يساوي صفر في تلك الحالتين وما عدا ذلك لا. من الجدير بالذكر
أنه في هذه الصيغة عندنا theta تظهر كوسيطة لدوال الجيب وجيب التمام بدل theta على 2 كما في متجه الحالة
الكمية الأصلي. وذلك لأننا استخدمنا تلك المتطابقات المثلثية اللي أولها ثلاثة هي أساساً
إعادة ترتيب لما يُسمى صيغ الزاوية المضاعفة. فالزاوية فعلياً تتضاعف. والآن أخيراً نحن جاهزين
نتكلم عن كرة Bloch نفسها. خلونا نركز على المعاملات الثلاثة لمصفوفات Pauli غير
الوحدوية في البسط لتعبير مصفوفة الكثافة. يعني نتجاهل الاثنين في
المقام ونتجاهل أيضاً مصفوفة الوحدة لأن معاملها ما يتغير أبداً. هذا لأن
ذلك المعامل يتحدد بأثر أي مصفوفة نعبر عنها ومصفوفات الكثافة دائماً أثرها يساوي
واحد. الآن تخيلوا أن عندنا ثلاثة محاور مسماة x و y و z موجهة وفقاً
لما يُسمى قاعدة اليد اليمنى واعتبروا النقطة اللي إحداثياتها تتطابق مع المعاملات الثلاثة. وللتوضيح هذا
فضاء ثلاثي الأبعاد عادي نتكلم عنه حيث الإحداثيات دائماً أعداد حقيقية.
الإحداثية x تقابل معامل مصفوفة Pauli sigma x في البسط لتعبيرنا وهي دائماً عدد حقيقي لأن مصفوفات
الكثافة هرميتية وكذلك لـ y و z. اللي نلقاه هو أن هذه النقطة اللي
نحصل عليها دائماً تكون على الكرة الوحدوية أو بعبارة أخرى الكرة ذات نصف القطر يساوي
واحد. وبالتحديد هي النقطة اللي نحصل عليها لو بدأنا من النقطة اللي يتقاطع فيها محور z الموجب مع الكرة
واللي نقدر نفكر فيها كالقطب الشمالي وندور للأسفل نحو محور x الموجب بزاوية theta ثم
ندور نحو محور y الموجب أو بعبارة أخرى شرقاً بزاوية phi. في هذا السياق الزاوية theta
تُسمى الزاوية القطبية وهذا سهل تذكره لأنها تبدأ من القطب. و phi تُسمى الزاوية
السمتية. ومعاً هاتان الزاويتان تمثلان الإحداثيات الكروية لنقاط على الكرة الوحدوية. وإذا
أردت تقدر أيضاً تخلي نصف القطر يتغير لتمثيل نقاط اعتباطية في الفضاء ثلاثي الأبعاد. لكن هنا نركز على نقاط على
الكرة الوحدوية حيث نصف القطر يساوي واحد. تقدر أيضاً تفكر في theta على أنها تمثل خط العرض إلا أننا نروح
من 0 إلى 180 درجة من القطب الشمالي للقطب الجنوبي بدل زائد ناقص 90 درجة من خط الاستواء. و phi تمثل
خط الطول حيث نعرّف أساساً خط الطول الرئيسي بأنه خط الطول اللي يتقاطع مع محور x
الموجب. إذا كنت مثلي بالمناسبة وتلخبط أيهما خط العرض وأيهما خط الطول ممكن يساعدك تتذكر
أن خط الطول يقابل الفترة الأطول 2 pi مقارنة بـ
pi. المهم النقطة اللي نحصل عليها على الكرة الوحدوية من متجه حالة الـ qubit psi بالتفكير في الإحداثيات بهذا
الشكل هي تمثيل كرة Bloch للحالة الكمية المقابلة لـ psi. ولما نفكر في الكرة الوحدوية
ثلاثية الأبعاد بالكامل بهذا الشكل نحصل على كرة Bloch. هندسياً هي مجرد كرة وحدوية
في الفضاء ثلاثي الأبعاد العادي لكن في الحقيقة هذا هو هندسة حالات
الـ qubit. هناك تناظر واحد لواحد مثالي هنا. كل حالة نقية لـ qubit تقابل نقطة وحيدة على
الكرة وكل نقطة على الكرة تمثل حالة qubit وحيدة حتى طور شامل. لما نشتغل بـ
متجهات الحالة الكمية هذا التناظر يُعرف بأسماء أخرى بالمناسبة. يُسمى أحياناً كرة Poincaré
مثلاً. لكن في سياق المعلومات الكمية يُشار إليه عموماً بكرة Bloch. لاحظوا أننا الآن نقدر نشوف
الانحلال في الزاوية phi بوضوح تام لأن خط الطول ما له معنى عند القطبين الشمالي والجنوبي. لكن ما عدا
القطبين كل نقطة على الأرض لها إحداثيات فريدة بدلالة خطي العرض والطول ونفس الشيء يصير هنا. هكذا
تشتغل كرة Bloch بشكل عام. الآن نلقي نظرة على بعض الأمثلة المحددة لحالات الـ qubit و
أين تقع على كرة Bloch. نبدأ بالأساس المعياري. هذه هي النقاط اللي نحصل عليها
لما الزاوية القطبية theta تساوي صفر لحالة الصفر و pi لحالة الواحد. هاتان هما الحالتان اللي
الزاوية السمتية phi غير ذات صلة فيهما كما ناقشت سابقاً. نقدر أيضاً نعبر عن مصفوفات الكثافة المقابلة كتوفيقات خطية
من مصفوفات Pauli. بأي طريقة نستنتج أن هاتين الحالتين تقابلان القطب الشمالي و
القطب الجنوبي لكرة Bloch. حالة الصفر في الأعلى وحالة الواحد في
الأسفل. بعد كذا نلقى حالتي الموجب والسالب على كرة Bloch. مرة أخرى نقدر نفكر إما بـ
متجهات الحالة الكمية أو مصفوفات الكثافة. لمتجهات الحالة الكمية هذه المرة الزاوية القطبية theta لازم تكون pi
على 2 عشان يصير مدخل الصفر 1 على جذر 2. الزاوية السمتية phi لازم تكون صفر
لحالة الموجب لأن مدخل الواحد موجب لحالة الموجب. ولازم تكون pi أو 180 درجة لحالة السالب
لأن ذلك المدخل سالب في تلك الحالة. فهاتان النقطتان تقعان على
خط استواء كرة Bloch. حالة الموجب حيث يتقاطع محور x الموجب مع الكرة وحالة السالب على الجانب المقابل حيث
محور x السالب يتقاطع مع الكرة. بالمقابل نقدر أيضاً نشوف من تعبيرات مصفوفة Pauli
لمصفوفات الكثافة المقابلة أن إحداثيتي y و z كلاهما صفر بينما إحداثيتا x موجبة وسالبة
واحد. مثال آخر هو أساس الموجب i السالب i وهو مشابه لأساس الموجب السالب إلا أننا نضرب أيضاً
مدخل الواحد بـ i الوحدة التخيلية. شفنا حالة الموجب i سابقاً في الدرس وحالة السالب i معرّفة
بشكل مماثل. الزاوية القطبية theta هي نفسها كما كانت لحالتي الموجب والسالب pi على
2. وهذه المرة نحتاج نختار الزاوية السمتية phi بحيث نحصل على i وسالب i بدل 1 وسالب 1
و pi على 2 و 3 pi على 2 هي الخيارات الصحيحة لتحقيق ذلك. مرة أخرى نقدر أيضاً ننظر إلى
أوصاف مصفوفة الكثافة لهذه الحالات والأشياء مشابهة جداً للمثالين السابقين إلا أنه هذه المرة مصفوفة Pauli y بدل
z أو x. فعلى كرة Bloch هاتان الحالتان تقعان حيث يتقاطع محور y
مع الكرة. وإذا رتبنا الأشياء شوي نقدر نشوف بوضوح أكبر كيف ترتبط الحالات الست اللي ناقشناها
ببعضها. لمثال واحد أخير أو فعلاً فئة من الأمثلة خذوا
متجهات الحالة الكمية لـ qubit اللي ظهرت سابقاً وفي الدرس الرابع حيث مدخل الصفر هو جيب تمام alpha لعدد حقيقي ما alpha ومدخل
الواحد هو جيب alpha. نقدر بالمناسبة نقصر اهتمامنا على قيم alpha بين صفر و pi لأن أي
قيمة أخرى لـ alpha راح تعطينا متجه متكافئ حتى طور شامل مع واحد حيث alpha في هذا
المدى. إذا حسبنا مصفوفات الكثافة المرتبطة بهذه الحالات معبَّراً عنها كتوافيق خطية من مصفوفات Pauli
نحصل على التعبير الموضح هنا على الشاشة. هذا الحساب مو موضح هنا لكن هذا هو اللي لازم
تحصلون عليه لو أجريتموه. واللي نلقاه هو أن هذه الحالات تشكل ما يُسمى دائرة عظمى تمر
عبر القطبين. تحديداً تبدأ من القطب الشمالي لما alpha يساوي صفر وتنزل على خط الطول الرئيسي و
توصل القطب الجنوبي لما alpha يساوي pi على 2 ثم ترجع للقطب الشمالي على الجانب المقابل من الكرة لما alpha يتراوح من pi على 2 إلى
pi. وهذا كله منطقي لأنه أولاً هذه متجهات حقيقية فالجزء التخيلي دائماً صفر وثانياً
الزاوية alpha فعلياً تتضاعف على كرة Bloch ومرة أخرى هذا يُفسَّر باستخدام
صيغ الزاوية المضاعفة. شفنا أن كرة Bloch توفر تمثيل هندسي جميل جداً للحالات النقية لـ
qubit حيث كل نقطة على الكرة تقابل حالة نقية وحيدة لـ qubit والعكس
صحيح. لما نشير إلى كرة Bloch المملوءة نتكلم عن كل النقاط على كرة Bloch وكذلك النقاط
الموجودة داخلها. النقاط في داخل كرة Bloch المملوءة تقابل أيضاً حالات qubit
تحديداً حالات ليست نقية. يعني بعبارة أخرى هذه حالات qubit يمكن تمثيلها بمصفوفات كثافة لكن ليس بمتجهات حالة
qubit. جانب أساسي في كرة Bloch المملوءة وطريقة تمثيل النقاط الداخلية للحالات غير النقية هو أن
التوافيق المحدبة للنقاط داخل كرة Bloch المملوءة تقابل التوافيق المحدبة لمصفوفات الكثافة.
بالحدس هذا يعني أن الهندسة تستمر بالعمل بشكل مثالي حتى داخل كرة Bloch
المملوءة. نلقي نظرة على مثالين نبدأ بنقطة المركز لكرة Bloch المملوءة واللي تمثل
الحالة المختلطة بالكامل. الحالة المختلطة بالكامل نحصل عليها بحساب متوسط حالتي الصفر والواحد وهذا متسق مع حقيقة
أن مركز الكرة بالضبط في منتصف المسافة بين القطب الشمالي والقطب الجنوبي. وفي الحقيقة هو في المنتصف بين أي نقطتين متقابلتين مثل
حالتي الموجب والسالب وحالتي الموجب i والسالب i. النقاط المتقابلة في كرة Bloch تقابل دائماً
حالات نقية متعامدة. وما يكشفه أو يعكسه هذا هو أننا نقدر دائماً نكتب الحالة المختلطة بالكامل
كمتوسط بين أي حالتين نقيتين متعامدتين لـ qubit. طريقة أخرى لرؤية هذا هي
التفكير في تمثيل مصفوفة Pauli للحالة المختلطة بالكامل. لتحقيق هذا لازم نحط
معاملات مصفوفات Pauli الثلاث غير الوحدوية كلها صفر وبالتالي النقطة المقابلة داخل
كرة Bloch المملوءة في المركز بالضبط عند نقطة الأصل. وبالمناسبة التفكير في تمثيلات مصفوفات Pauli لمصفوفات
الكثافة بهذا الشكل يوضح فعلاً أن التوافيق المحدبة لنقاط كرة Bloch المملوءة تقابل التوافيق
المحدبة لمصفوفات الكثافة. إذا أخذنا متوسط أو متوسط موزون لمصفوفات الكثافة و
عبرنا عن كل شيء بدلالة توافيق خطية من مصفوفات Pauli فطبعاً نحسب متوسط النقاط المقابلة لأن كل
شيء خطي في تلك المعاملات الثلاثة. لمثال واحد أخير خذوا متوسط حالة الصفر
وحالة الموجب اللي شفناها سابقاً في الدرس. حسبنا تمثيل مصفوفة الكثافة الموضح على
الشاشة وعندنا أن النقطة في داخل كرة Bloch المملوءة في منتصف المسافة بين حالتي الصفر والموجب.
شفنا أيضاً أننا نقدر نعبر عن مصفوفة الكثافة هذه بطريقة مختلفة بناءً على تحليلها الطيفي و
مرة أخرى هذا متسق مع الرسم والأمثلة السابقة. وبهذا نختتم
مناقشة كرة Bloch وكرة Bloch المملوءة. الناس كثير يسألون إذا كان هناك كرة Bloch أو كرة Bloch مملوءة للأنظمة اللي عندها
ثلاث حالات كلاسيكية أو أكثر والجواب للأسف مو فعلاً. نقدر دائماً نفكر في
الحالات الكمية لنظام بمصطلحات هندسية مشابهة لكرة Bloch المملوءة وراح نحصل على جسم محدب في فضاء متجهي
حقيقي. لكن إذا كان عندنا ثلاث حالات كلاسيكية أو أكثر ما راح يكون كروي. مثلاً إذا كان عندنا
بالضبط ثلاث حالات كلاسيكية أو qutrit باختصار راح نحصل على جسم محدب في فضاء ثماني
الأبعاد لكن النقاط المتطرفة لذلك الجسم واللي تقابل الحالات الكمية النقية لـ qutrit راح تكون
رباعية الأبعاد فقط. إذا تقدر تتخيل أنك تاخذ متعددة أبعاد رباعية في فضاء ثماني الأبعاد وتلفها بغلاف بلاستيكي لتحصل على جسم محدب
وتلقى هذا طريقة مفيدة للتفكير في الـ qutrit فأكثر قوة لك أفترض. هذا مثير للتفكير فيه
لكنه مو كرة، هو أعقد من كذا. في الجزء الأخير من الدرس راح نناقش باختصار
كيف تشتغل مصفوفات الكثافة للأنظمة المتعددة. مصفوفات الكثافة تقدر تمثل حالات أنظمة متعددة وهذا
يشتغل بطريقة مماثلة تماماً لمتجهات الحالة الكمية. بالتحديد تماماً مثل ما عندنا في الصياغة المبسطة للمعلومات
الكمية نقدر ننظر لأنظمة متعددة معاً كأنها أنظمة مركبة
مفردة. هذه المرة كل من صفوف وأعمدة مصفوفات الكثافة اللي تمثل حالات أنظمة متعددة
توضع في تناظر مع الجداء الديكارتي لمجموعات الحالات الكلاسيكية للأنظمة الفردية. مثلاً نقدر نأخذ
تمثيلات مصفوفة الكثافة لحالات Bell الأربع واللي نحصل عليها بالضبط كما فعلنا لمتجهات الحالة
الكمية الأخرى سابقاً في الدرس بضرب متجهات الحالة في مرافقاتها المنقولة والنتائج موضحة هنا على
الشاشة. أساساً ما في شيء جديد على المستوى المفاهيمي رغم أننا راح نشوف قريباً أنه توجد بعض
الأشياء الجديدة اللي نقدر نسويها بمصفوفات الكثافة للأنظمة المتعددة. مفاهيم الاستقلالية
والارتباطات تنتقل من متجهات الحالة الكمية إلى مصفوفات الكثافة. وبالتحديد نلقى أن جداءات التنسور
لمصفوفات الكثافة تمثل الاستقلالية بين الأنظمة. نستخدم نفس المصطلحات اللي
استخدمناها لمتجهات الحالة الكمية. مثلاً إذا كان عندنا نظام X محضَّر في حالة rho ونظام Y
محضَّر بشكل مستقل في حالة sigma فإن حالة الزوج XY معاً تُعطى بجداء التنسور
لـ rho و sigma. نسمي هذا حالة جداء وهذا يتعمم بشكل طبيعي لأكثر من
نظامين. مصفوفات الكثافة اللي ما يمكن التعبير عنها كحالات جداء تمثل ارتباطات بين الأنظمة وهذا
الجزء مشابه لمتجهات الحالة الكمية. لكن كما اتضح هناك أنواع مختلفة من الارتباطات ممكن تنشأ لما نستخدم مصفوفات الكثافة حتى
لنظامين فقط. بالمقابل هناك فعلاً نوع واحد فقط من الارتباط ممكن يكون لمتجهات الحالة الكمية و
هو التشابك. بعبارة أخرى الارتباط والتشابك مترادفان لمتجهات الحالة الكمية لكن
هذا مو صحيح لمصفوفات الكثافة. هنا الأشياء أكثر إثارة. مثلاً نقدر نوصف
الحالات الكلاسيكية المترابطة بمصفوفات الكثافة. هنا مثال على مصفوفة كثافة تمثل بت عشوائي كلاسيكي
مشترك بين Alice و Bob. دائماً عندهم نفس الحالة الكلاسيكية صفر أو واحد والاحتمال
1/2 لكل من الاحتمالين. هذه ليست حالة متشابكة. التشابك غير كلاسيكي لكن
هي حالة مترابطة. مثال آخر مرتبط بمفهوم مجموعة من الحالات الكمية
واللي تقدر تفكر فيها كتوزيع احتمالي على مجموعة منتهية من الحالات الكمية. بالتحديد تخيلوا أن
عندنا m مصفوفة كثافة rho صفر إلى rho m ناقص واحد كلها تمثل حالات ممكنة لنظام معين
مع احتمال لسحب كل واحدة. لو أردنا نقدر نحسب المتوسط الموزون لمصفوفات
الكثافة هذه بأخذ توفيقة محدبة لكن هذا ما يخبرنا فعلاً ماهي الحالات الفردية أو ماهي
الاحتمالات. اللي نقدر نسويه بدل كذا وأحياناً مفيد جداً أن نسويه هو أن نأخذ مصفوفة
كثافة بالشكل الموضح هنا على الشاشة. هذه حالة لنظامين حيث النظام الأول عنده حالة كلاسيكية واحدة
لكل من البدائل وناخذ المتوسط الموزون لـ m حالة جداء حيث حالة النظام
الأول دائماً كلاسيكية وأساساً تسمّي أي من الحالات الـ m عندنا للنظام
الثاني. إذا مو واضح بالضبط ليش نبي نفكر بحالات مثل هذه فلا بأس. هو مجرد مثال على
نوع من الارتباط حيث النظام الأول دائماً كلاسيكي والنظام الثاني ممكن يكون في حالة
كمية. فئة ثالثة من الحالات الممكن مترابطة هي مجموعة ما يُسمى بالحالات
القابلة للفصل. بعبارات بسيطة هذه توافيق محدبة من حالات الجداء وهي أساساً تمثل حالات كمية
حيث أي ارتباطات بين الأنظمة هي ارتباطات كلاسيكية. طريقة واحدة للتفكير في
حالات مثل هذه هي أننا نسوي اختيار احتمالي لرقم k ثم نحضّر بشكل مستقل نظامين
في حالة كمية ممكن تعتمد على هذا الاختيار لـ k. اللي ربما أكثر إثارة عن
حالات بهذا الشكل هو أن هذه هي فعلاً الطريقة اللي نعرّف فيها التشابك بمصطلحات رياضية. بالتحديد التشابك
يُعرَّف بأنه غياب القابلية للفصل. فإذا عندك مصفوفة كثافة وما يمكن التعبير عنها بشكل
مثل هذا فبالتعريف هي متشابكة. ألمحت لهذا في الدرس الرابع وها هو بتفصيل
أكبر. بالمناسبة ممكن يكون صعب جداً معرفة إذا كانت مصفوفة كثافة معينة تمثل حالة متشابكة
حتى بمساعدة الكمبيوتر. رياضياً وحسابياً التشابك
فعلاً معقد جداً. ذكرت في بداية الدرس أن هناك شيء مهم جداً نقدر نسويه بمصفوفات الكثافة وهو
وصف حالات الأجزاء المعزولة من الأنظمة حتى لما تكون مترابطة وربما متشابكة مع أنظمة
أخرى. مصطلح الحالة المختزلة يُستخدم كثيراً في هذا السياق وكمثال بسيط راح نحسب الحالات المختزلة
للـ qubit الفردية اللي تشكل ebit. لنكون دقيقين نفترض أن
Alice و Bob يتشاركان ebit. Alice تحمل qubit اسمه A و Bob يحمل qubit اسمه B ومعاً هذان الـ qubit في حالة
phi plus. والسؤال اللي راح نجيب عليه هو ما هي حالة qubit الـ A الخاص بـ Alice
بمعزل عن الآخر؟ طبعاً نقدر نسأل نفس السؤال عن qubit الـ B الخاص بـ Bob لكن سهل نجيب عليه لما نعرف الجواب على هذا
السؤال. الآن ممكن يكون مغري أن نقول إننا ما نقدر نوصف حالة qubit الـ Alice بمعزل لأنه
متشابك مع qubit الـ Bob واللي ممكن بطريقة ما يمنعنا من وصف أو حتى التفكير في حالة A
بمعزل. لكن هذا خاطئ. صحيح أننا ما نقدر نوصف حالة A بمتجه حالة
كمية لأنه كما راح نشوف مو في حالة نقية. لكن كل نظام عنده حالة في أي لحظة معينة يمكن
وصفها بمصفوفة كثافة سواء كان متشابك مع نظام آخر أو لا. كتجربة فكرية بس لنساعد
أنفسنا نشوف ماهو الجواب على هذا السؤال، نفترض أن Bob قرر ياخذ الـ qubit حقه ويسافر للنجوم وما يُسمع عنه
أبداً بعدها. لكن تخيلوا أنه في مكان ما على الطريق يقرر يسوي قياس أساس معياري على
الـ qubit حقه. نعرف كيف نحسب الاحتمالات لحصوله على النتيجتين الممكنتين ونعرف أيضاً ماذا
راح تكون حالة A لكل نتيجة ممكنة وتلك الأشياء ملخصة في هذا الجدول. بالتحديد باحتمال 1/2
A راح تكون في حالة الصفر وباحتمال 1/2 A راح تكون في حالة الواحد. وكما نوقش سابقاً في
الدرس هذا يترك A في الحالة المختلطة بالكامل وبالتالي هذا هو الجواب
على سؤالنا. الآن ممكن تعترض وتقول إن هذا يعتمد على حقيقة أن
Bob قرر يقيس الـ qubit حقه وافتراض أنه يسوي هذا هو جزء من القصة اللي قادتنا لهذا الجواب. لكن
إذا Bob على بعد سنوات ضوئية بالوقت اللي يقيس فيه ما في شيء يسويه ممكن يؤثر على أي
تجربة ممكن Alice تقرر تسويها على الـ qubit حقها. وإلا كان عندنا اتصال أسرع من
الضوء. فـ qubit الـ Alice في الحالة المختلطة بالكامل بغض النظر عما إذا كان Bob
قاس أو لا. لازم أوضح في هذه النقطة أن مفهوم الحالة المختزلة والطريقة اللي تُعرَّف فيها ما عندها فعلاً أي اعتماد على النسبية
أو استحالة الاتصال الأسرع من الضوء. هذه مجرد طريقة لشرحها بمصطلحات حدسية بإذن الله.
في الحقيقة هناك تعريف رياضي راح نشوفه في سياق أعم بعد لحظات. هو متسق مع هذا الجواب
وبالصدفة مع استحالة الاتصال الأسرع من الضوء وأيضاً ما في تعريف
آخر ممكن يكون متسق مع المعلومات الكمية كما نعرفها. الآن نأخذ الحالات المختزلة بشكل
أعم. افترض أن عندنا زوج من الأنظمة A و B مو بالضرورة qubit اللي معاً في حالة نقية
ممثلة بمتجه حالة كمية psi. مرة أخرى راح نركز على الحالة المختزلة للنظام A ولسوي
هذا من المفيد التفكير في الحالات الكلاسيكية للنظام B فخلوا gamma تكون هذه المجموعة من
الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ B. كما ناقشنا سابقاً مثلاً في الدرس الثاني من السلسلة
هناك مجموعة وحيدة من المتجهات phi b لكل b في gamma بحيث تعبير psi الموضح على الشاشة
صحيح. وبالتحديد هناك صيغة بسيطة لهذه المتجهات. ببساطة نضرب المتجه psi في
جداء التنسور لمصفوفة الوحدة المقابلة للنظام A مع bra b لأي b نهتم
به. اللي نسويه هنا أساساً هو أننا نجهز أنفسنا لحساب ماذا سيحصل لو أجرينا
قياس أساس معياري على B. ومرة أخرى هذا تم تغطيته في الدرس الثاني من
السلسلة. لو أجرينا فعلاً قياس أساس معياري على B كل نتيجة ممكنة راح
تظهر باحتمال يساوي مربع المعيار الإقليدي للمتجه المقابل phi b. وبشرط الحصول على
نتيجة معينة b نقوم بتطبيع المتجه phi b لتحديد الحالة الناتجة
لـ A. باتباع نفس المنطق كما في مثال الـ ebit قبل لحظات نحصل على التعبير الموضح على
الشاشة للحالة المختزلة لـ A كمصفوفة كثافة. وبالمناسبة مربع المعيار في المقام يأتي من
ضرب المتجه المطبَّع في مرافقه المنقول فنحصل على المعيار الإقليدي مرتين في
المقام. مربعات المعيار الإقليدي تُلغي ونبقى بتعبير بسيط
جداً. وفي الحقيقة إذا عوّضنا بصيغتنا لـ phi b واللي تشتغل لكل b نحصل على صيغة للحالة المختزلة
للنظام A بدلالة وصف مصفوفة الكثافة للحالة النقية اللي بدأنا فيها وهي ket psi
bra psi. هذه صيغتنا للحالة المختزلة للنظام A بفرض أن النظام المركب AB بدأ في
الحالة النقية psi. لكن نقدر أيضاً نستخدم الصيغة بشكل أعم. بالتحديد نفترض
أن حالة AB تُعطى بمصفوفة كثافة ما rho واللي ممكن تكون بشكل ket psi bra psi لمتجه حالة
كمية ما psi لكن مو بالضرورة. يتبع أساساً بالخطية أن الحالة المختزلة لـ A
تتحدد بنفس الصيغة اللي كانت عندنا للحالات النقية إلا أننا نعوض بأي مصفوفة كثافة rho
نشاء. كترميز مختصر شائع جداً أننا نسمي هذه الحالة المختزلة بأي اسم نستخدمه لمصفوفة
الكثافة rho في هذه الحالة لكن نحط رمز سفلي يشير للنظام اللي نركز عليه. فـ rho مع رمز
سفلي A تعني الحالة المختزلة لـ A لما النظام المركب في حالة rho. الرموز العلوية أيضاً تُستخدم أحياناً
بدل الرموز السفلية. هو أساساً مجرد تفضيل شخصي ويعني نفس
الشيء. كنا نركز على النظام A بس للبساطة لكن نقدر أيضاً نحصل على الحالة المختزلة للنظام B
بشكل مماثل لكن حيث الصيغة تتكيف بالطريقة الطبيعية. كل شيء متماثل هنا
أساساً نبدل أدوار A و B. وبالتحديد المجموع يكون على الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ A هذه المرة
بدل B. وفي الصيغة على الشاشة نفترض أن مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ A تُسمى
sigma. كل هذا يتعمم بطريقة مباشرة جداً لثلاثة أنظمة أو أكثر. مثلاً إذا كان عندنا ثلاثة
أنظمة A و B و C اللي مجتمعة في الحالة الموصوفة بمصفوفة الكثافة rho فنقدر نحصل على
الحالة المختزلة للزوج AB معاً بالصيغة الموضحة هنا وكذلك حالة النظام الثالث وحده
وهي الصيغة الثانية. وتقدرون تأخذون تركيبات أخرى وتعممون هذا لأي عدد من الأنظمة تريدون. المجاميع دائماً تُؤخذ على
مجموعات الحالات الكلاسيكية للأنظمة اللي يتم تجاهلها والنمط دائماً نفسه مع مصفوفة
الكثافة اللي بدأنا فيها محصورة بين جداء التنسور لمصفوفة الوحدة و bra و ket المقابلة لحالات الأساس
المعياري. لنختم الدرس راح أقول شوي أكثر عن التعريفات اللي غطيناها للتو. العملية على مصفوفات
الكثافة اللي توصف الحالات المختزلة عندها اسم وتُسمى الأثر الجزئي. لنظامين A و B
الأثر الجزئي على B والأثر الجزئي على A معرّفان كما هو موضح هنا على الشاشة. هذه بالضبط نفس
الصيغ اللي شفناها قبل لحظات والآن نفكر فيها بس كدوال لـ rho ونعطيها
أسماء. الأسماء تبدو مثل الأثر إلا أنه هناك رمز سفلي يخبرنا أي نظام يتم إزالته
أو بعبارة أخرى أي نظام مجموعة حالاته الكلاسيكية نجمع عليها ويتم حصره بين bra و
ket. لما ناخذ الأثر الجزئي على B مثلاً واللي يوصفه الصيغة الأولى أحياناً نقول إن
B يُتتبع عليه وكذلك لـ A. بالحدس تتبع
نظام يعني ببساطة أننا نرميه أو نتجاهله. هذه طريقة واحدة لتعريف الأثر
الجزئي وطريقة مكافئة أخرى هي أن نقول إن هذه التطبيقات هي التطبيقات الخطية الوحيدة اللي تستوفي
الصيغ الموضحة هنا على اليمين. تحديداً إذا كان عندنا جداء تنسور لمصفوفتين M و N
مثلاً وأجرينا الأثر الجزئي على النظام الأول فاللي نحصل عليه هو أثر المصفوفة الأولى M ضرب
المصفوفة الثانية. والشرط متماثل لما نتتبع على النظام الثاني. مو كل مصفوفة
نحسب أثرها الجزئي هي جداء تنسور بهذا الشكل لكن كل مصفوفة يمكن التعبير عنها كتوفيقة خطية من
جداءات تنسور ونقدر نحدد الأثر الجزئي من هذه الشروط مع حقيقة أنها دوال
خطية. وعشان كذا يُسمى الأثر الجزئي. هذا التعريف المكافئ ممكن
يكون مفيد جداً لأننا غالباً نقدر نستخدمه بدل الصيغة الأصلية. هنا مثال
يوضح هذا. افترض أن عندنا زوج من الـ qubit في الحالة اللي مصفوفة كثافتها موضحة هنا على
الشاشة. هذا يصادف أنه مثال على حالة مترابطة حيث A إما في حالة الصفر أو حالة الواحد كل
منهما باحتمال 1/2. فنقدر نفكر في A على أنه كلاسيكي. إذا A في حالة الصفر
فكذلك B. وإذا A في حالة الواحد فـ B في حالة الموجب. إذا نبي نعرف ماهي الحالة المختزلة لـ A
نتتبع على B. وإذا استخدمنا الصيغة الثانية من التعريف المكافئ مع الخطية فنقدر
نحسب هذا بسهولة كبيرة. بالتحديد أثر ket 0 bra 0 يساوي واحد وكذلك أثر ket plus bra
plus. فتختفي عوامل التنسور تلك ونبقى بالحالة المختلطة بالكامل. بنفس الطريقة نقدر نحسب
الحالة المختزلة لـ B بالتتبع على A. هذه المرة عامل التنسور الأول هو اللي نجري عليه الأثر
فنستخدم الصيغة الأولى من التعريف المكافئ ونبقى بـ 1/2 ضرب ket 0 bra 0 زائد 1/2 ضرب ket
plus bra plus. أو بعبارة أخرى نفس مصفوفة الكثافة اللي ظهرت عدة مرات سابقاً. راح تحصلون على بالضبط نفس
النتائج لو استخدمتم الصيغ من التعريف الأول لكن هذه طريقة أسهل بكثير. كل هذا يتعمم لثلاثة أنظمة أو أكثر
لكن لهذا الفيديو راح أتوقف هنا وأترك هذا لكم تفكرون فيه بأنفسكم. وبهذا ننتهي من هذا الدرس اللي
قدّم مصفوفات الكثافة ووصف أساسيات كيف تشتغل. ناقشنا أيضاً كرة Bloch
وكذلك أنواع مختلفة من الارتباطات ومفهوم الحالة المختزلة لنظام. أتمنى تنضمون لي في
الدرس القادم اللي عن القنوات وهي تطبيقات خطية من مصفوفات الكثافة إلى مصفوفات الكثافة واللي
توصف العمليات على الأنظمة. إلى اللقاء حتى
ذلك الحين